Robert Manning five years ago you put
out a report called credit cards on
campus what has changed since in those
five years well I think what's striking
is that we've had a national discussion
on the future of credit and the role
that students should play in terms of
their fiscal and personal responsibility
and yet on the other hand so much has
not changed while six to eight hundred
colleges around the country have
addressed the problem suit through some
forms of limited restrictions of
marketing on campus the ability of
having students understand their
financial obligations and improving
their personal literacy skills has not
improved and so it's absolutely shocking
today to see that we've recognized
there's a problem but we're really not
fighting to help it how many credit
cards on average does a student have
well by the time a student graduates
from college we're talking about Nellie
Mae said in 201 now the average debt is
about twenty thousand dollars about
thirty five hundred dollars as credit
card debt and the average student will
have at least three credit cards plus
retail cards and has the marketing of
that those credit cards changed any
since you came out with the report well
I think what's so disturbing in terms of
our most recent study is that we're
seeing the intensification of marketing
pressures in the high schools today that
between 1999 and 2001 we saw that the
number of students who said they started
using credit cards in high school has
tripled it's the federal government
aren't there rules though against
marketing of credit cards to high school
students well the marketing is one thing
actually entering into a contract is
another and there's a bit of a public
misnomer that people think that if
they're 17 years old that a young person
cannot get a credit card the reality is
that a credit card company cannot
enforce a contract with someone who's
under 18 years old it's not that they
can't give them a credit card if they're
17 years old the topic is credit cards
and college students our guest is Robert
Manning he's the author of the book
credit card nation the consequences of
America's addiction to credit one of
three lines you can call in on this
morning this time we're going to split
the lines by ages if you're under 25
years old give us a call at 202 five
eight five three
zero if you are over 25 years old
202 585 388 one we've also set aside a
line for our international viewers this
morning
202 five eight five three eight eight
three the way we split our lines one of
the things we wanted to look is the
mentality that various age groups have
towards credit is there a split between
how younger people and maybe older
people view credit well that's such a
good point Pedro I I like to refer to it
as the new school versus old school
values that old Puritan ethic that you
save for that proverbial rainy day
really has strong generational
connections where you pay as you go
whereas today the new generation is
encouraged where that just do it
consumerism and that you take care of
business and maintain your lifestyle
today and worry about paying for it
tomorrow very clear demarcation by
generations couple two years ago the
Senate taking a look at this issue on a
hearing on financial literacy among
college students what came out of that
well I think what was most intriguing in
this report for your listeners just was
published about two months ago was the
stark debate on the one hand that the
industry says that no there really isn't
a problem that you know some people are
going to be using credit card but cards
but they generally use them in a prudent
and acceptable fashion what we had by
having a wider array of student groups
and college administrators was a
discussion now that credit cards have
emerged as problems in many different
areas whether its students who have to
work longer hours now and it's
detracting from their studies whether
they're having difficulties with higher
levels of debt of even renting an
apartment on campus or the shock of
finding out that they may not get loans
for graduate school or even get rejected
for a job application because of
questions raised by their imprudent use
of consumer credit study done in 2002 by
George Mason said that 80% of high
college seniors had maxed out their
credit cards 70% had used credit cards
to pay for other credit cards I think
what was most disturbing about this
study was that we saw credit card misuse
as early as the first semester of the
freshman year
that we're seeing already students
saying in their freshman year even
though their lines of credit are low but
already they're maxing out and in fact
what we saw was a consistent use of
students who said that they had credit
cards three out of force that had
student loans said they use their
student loans to pay down their credit
cards this of course is a recipe for
disaster when they graduate because
suddenly they're going to have to pay
for their student loans and credit cards
which they're not being trained to do in
college did they have to use the credit
cards though for necessities or were
these just disposable income kind of
purchases we'll again very good point
different groups of campus that are now
part of our freshman class we've had a
surge of new immigrants a large increase
in first-generation college students in
America we want to have a democratic
educational system so increasingly we
have students from lower-income groups
who now are finding it difficult to pay
their way in college so we have students
who have had mom and dad pay for
everything in high school and think that
they should be paying those same
activities while they're in college and
use their credit cards with same degree
of imprudence as well as we have
students from difficult backgrounds who
can't pay tuition or their parents need
some help with the rent and they're
using those credit cards to make up
those differences Long Beach California
good morning good morning go ahead
you're on how's it going out there I
just want to comment on the number of
marketers on campus because I still see
a an increasing number of marketers now
they're promoting with a lot more free
gifts I mean there are when I first
started cause four years ago it was will
give you one free gift or two four gifts
now they're giving it eight nine ten
free gifts plus gym membership so they
can get you on the credit card list I
mean I made a big mistake if I had you
know three three four credit cards my
freshman year well I think what's
important here is what exactly is being
sold and what's critical now is that
with the changing nature of the banking
system where we have a Citigroup that
sells credit cards mortgages insurances
investment services credit cards are
being used to get
people into the data banks and the
assumption is is that the sooner you get
a young person in the data bank the more
different services and products that can
be sold that's why we're seeing this
race to the bottom that's why we're
seeing the contracting out of marketing
on campus so that big credit-card
companies don't have to be held
accountable for some of the unethical
and in some cases illegal marketing
practices where students may apply for
one credit card and the marketer on
campus may Forge their name on three or
four different applications so that they
can get those fees for four different
cards on our line for those over 25
portsmouth ohio well go ahead I just
want to talk to mr. Manning in regards
to young people being responsible I'm 75
year old fellow at this time and I work
for Sears Roebuck and Company at that
time through the years but when you get
credit cards I've always been able
fortunately the pay off in 30 days I
that was just a rule that I made and the
biggest thing I got about credit card
companies is that they just bombard you
know I get bombarded with more cards
more cards more cards you can have up to
any limit you know and that kind of
thing and but some people aren't
responsive enough to turn them back
there's another point I want to make
about credit card companies I think that
John Edwards had it pretty much on I'm a
Republican but more that he wanted to
restrict some of these credit card
companies from being predators on our
young people and so forth about the
interest rate now the interest rate I
think should be set fairly for them but
not up to 25 percent they can take away
on caller thanks well you know several
issues are being raised here in the
caller who's seventy-five years young
had a different experience with banks in
the older days the best customer was
someone who could pay off their loans
their debts today with the high interest
rates where the average student that
gets a credit card will have an interest
rate of maybe eighteen to twenty three
percent the best client is someone who
will never pay off their credit cards
and what's clear what is so important
and key here is that we
need to strike a balance between the
rights of banks and American capitalism
to make a profit and the understanding
of having an informed citizenry that's
making the right decision for them what
we have instead here is essentially
credit being given out as if it's free
and a lack of the understanding because
in the old days a young person had to
earn the privilege to get credit by
having a job in having a good payment
history today it's far easy for an
eighteen year old to get a credit card
who's never had a job than their
grandparents who are retired does the
federal government is have they gotten
more involved in this issue as the years
have progressed yes and no I mean there
have been more hearings more sensitivity
more constituents complaining the
reality is is that all federal
legislation except for one bill never
even came up for a floor vote some
amendments have been introduced trying
to improve the balance by encouraging or
requiring some greater form of financial
literacy classes on college campuses but
none of those have successfully passed
why not why not more of an interest from
the legislators well what we have and as
we see with this current election seven
or eight of the top ten financial
contributors to President Bush's
reelection campaign are from financial
services this is one of the most
profitable sectors of the American
economy and this if you may race to the
bottom
of getting young people into the credit
system as soon as possible is seen as
one of the most profitable segments of
this revolving credit portfolio so
restricting access to this group is seen
as an inanimate to the industry green
when Deanna yes I was just calling to
say sorry I'm kind of nervous but a
phone card companies do the same thing
phone companies 18t they sent me a free
phone card saying I had a pre certain
amount of minutes and a beeper and then
I got like a two hundred dollar bill for
that and I mean and I was only eight the
time and how he was for that and I also
had friends
getting credit cards and spending it in
on whatever they wanted to and not even
putting true information on the on their
credit card things and I mean they were
just approved that easily so I just want
to make that comment thank well and
again I think one of the problems is
it's so profitable and the markets have
been saturated with the traditional
middle-income earning households that
have credit cards and phone cards etc
beepers cell phones that what's left to
expand is been young people and older
people and at these high interest rates
the industry is very happy to have a few
people who aren't who are going to
default or become delinquent and simply
sell them off to debt collectors this is
an industry where profits drive an
expanding market without any restraint
in terms of who can afford these
particular products Summerville Georgia
I don't understand how a college
students they usually has no work and no
credit how did they get a credit card I
tried four since I was 20 and I just got
my first credit card last year and
decent credit they always said I never
had enough credit to receive a critic
order and then that gets me what are
they lying on their application well
that's a really good point because a lot
of people who pay in cash actually are
not building up a good credit history
and one of the points about recruiting
college students as they're told this is
the best way to establish good credit
which isn't true you could have utility
bills and other installment type credit
contracts what the caller doesn't
realize is that the banks explicitly
market to college students and even
seniors in high school knowing that they
can have a student loan summer earnings
or even their parents to help them out
if they become delinquent with their
bills so the industry has recognized
that college students even though they
don't have a job are no less likely to
default than the population at large
through parents automatically assume the
responsibility if a college student
can't meet a credit card obligation well
you know that's a real interesting point
because in the late
ATS the restrictions on credit were
primarily that parents had to co-sign
and until the early 90s the bank's
realized that cosign credit card
students didn't buy as much so they
stopped for requiring parental
signatures but when students defaulted
they still sued the parents anyway it
wasn't until about 93 or so that the
court cases ruled against the banking
industry and they couldn't sue parents
whose children defaulted what they did
instead was simply SiC the debt
collectors on parents and say hey do you
want to ruin your child's future over
six or seven thousand dollars and
parents would pay up three lines if
you're under 25 years old a line for you
if you are over 25 and we also have
international viewers this morning the
line specially for you saying Louis
Missouri on are under 25 line okay I
don't think that they should give
students credit cards unless they're
going to educate them in school because
if if they would have educated me I
wouldn't have got two of them at the age
of eighteen and there were only a 500
dollar limit and because I didn't know
about the interest rates and how I had
to pay every month and keep up
everything they got up to $1,800 and now
I'm 21 and I still owe three hundred
twenty two dollars and I live on my own
I can't even afford college and there's
no one to help me so I mean I really
think they should educate people and I
would be able to put my money elsewhere
well you know let's be clear credit
cards are one of the most extraordinary
revolutions of the information
technology and if they're used well and
effectively they're an extraordinary
convenience the problem is for people
who don't understand how credit is used
effectively and find themselves in deep
amount of debt the fees the default
rates the high interest rates the
over-limit fees etc add up and
accumulate what I've recommended is that
every student should come to college and
get a $500 credit card learn how to use
it but it can't be raised if there's
been any problems with repayment and
that every year if a parent wouldn't
co-sign for that credit card and the
person paid it off irregularly they
would get up to $500
their line of credit card up to 2000
when they graduated this would help
prevent the huge problems of students
who can't possibly pay their credit
cards from using one credit card to pay
another and end up with 10 or $15,000 in
credit card debt in the absence of
schools and state legislators of taking
the responsibility and saying hey it's a
new reality out there students need to
learn the appropriate use of credit this
would be one restriction that could help
the worst case scenarios from occurring
there's a story in The Washington Post
this morning
the caller talked about fees and that
this story deals with something called
borrowers Protection Plan how do they
work well this is interesting because
unlike credit insurance which requires
monitoring by state regulators this is
essentially debt insurance and all that
happens is that you don't have to pay
your minimum payment when a certain
trigger has occurred such as you've lost
your job you're ill other forms of
family crises a divorce a widowhood etc
basically this occurrence is pretty much
bogus because there's no guarantee of
what percentage should be the payout and
essentially nobody will ever get more
out of these programs than they've paid
in because of the way the contracts are
structured so in other words if you owe
$5,000 in your credit cards you are not
required to pay your minimum payment for
let's say 18 months and then it expires
and regardless of whether you found a
job or not
you've got to go back to paying your
minimum payments the revenues from this
now our billion-dollar industry we can't
get a fix at all of what the benefit is
to the consumer other than it's a lot
more profitable than credit insurance
and we know that credit insurance really
isn't as useful to the consumer as its
portrayed Little Rock Arkansas for our
guest Robert Manning I wonder if you
think there's a change maybe in
attitudes or are college students and
young adults intending to pay these
debts or is this just part of the of
their culture now
and they talk openly about their
bankruptcies with without much
embarrassment it seems to me well you
know there's two points there one of
course personal bankruptcy we had a
record last year 1.6 million over the
last decade over 11 million people have
filed for bankruptcy so clearly it's
easier to go into bankruptcy than it was
before but it also is suggesting to us
that there's some watershed events that
are going on in our society that people
young people certainly when they enter
into an agreement they expect they're
going to pay off their debts but the
problem is there's a disconnect with the
reality universities say hey the best
investment you're gonna make is a
college degree the banks say you work
hard in college
it's a full-time job you just don't get
paid for it they are encouraging this
unrealistically optimistic view of the
future upon graduation and the
assumption is you're going to get a
great job and you're gonna pay all this
off and everything is going to be fine
the reality is of course we're in a
jobless recovery there's a lot of
turnover and jobs young people get a job
for a year or two and find themselves
unemployed for a few months and they
have to rely on their credit cards as
bridge loans if you may so what's
changed is the assumption that good jobs
are gonna make up for high levels of
debt young people don't understand that
reality when they graduate Newark
Delaware hi just wanted to ask the
caller if you could give me an S the
total amount of credit card that credit
losses in the United States today net
credit card debt today is about 620
billion dollars and if you look at it as
an average of households that are in
debt it's about $13,000 per household
and that's an underestimate when you
look at the fact that home equity loans
for example a fastest increase in in
loans today the number one reason people
say that they take them is to pay down
their credit cards caller do you have a
follow up not fair Hall in Massachusetts
thank you for taking my call I wanted to
make a comment about the generational
issue concerning credit card debt my own
um is what I will draw on which is that
my father never had a credit card until
he was in his 50s he was depression-era
raised of course and and believed in
paying cash for everything and only when
it became really necessary he had to
travel for his job and when hotels and
rental car companies began requiring
credit cards in order to use them he
finally acquiesced and got one he raised
us to be fiscally responsible as
children although I must say my own
experience was that although I didn't
get a credit card I'm 52 now until I was
30 I still got myself into the same
situation that many of these young
people are getting themselves into now I
accumulated a huge credit card debt did
the same thing used credit card to pay
credit card and ultimately was able to
pay it off only when I received a lump
sum inheritance payment
what I find since I work in the service
industry I'm self-employed service
provider
I find that my generation the baby
boomer generation has really not taught
their children to be fiscally
responsible I see many of the people
that I work for paying bills for their
children paying even parking tickets etc
so that when people of this age start to
get credit cards I tend to think that
they don't really have a sense that they
are ever going to have to really pay the
piper so to speak thank you for your
time and I will listen to your answer
well I think what's really important
here is that things have changed
generationally as well as what the
expectations are in terms of how much
debt we can get into and how we can
repay it I'm doing a lot of comparative
working in Europe and there's a lot of
discussion as the federal government is
withdrawing regulations what they calls
the decline of the nanny state they say
that citizens have to be more informed
that if the banks are going to be
offering you these lines of credit that
you should be at least well educated
enough to know if you can afford to take
on that level of debt and do you
understand the terms of that contract
here in the United States we're seeing
similar issues happening where there's
less federal and state regulation but
there isn't the response of how to
educate citizens to become
more informed in the decisions that were
making and I see that's the real
breakdown in terms of striking a balance
between people's needs for credit banks
obligations to their shareholders to
make a profit and responsible lending is
there evidence to show what the
attitudes towards credit cards among
students for international and compare
them to the United States that's really
interesting point that's that's a study
that we've been working on this year in
fact and what we find is that
international students are actually
shocked to see how much credit people
can get without earning it a sense of is
there a worthiness factor involved and
when they come from their home countries
and it's more likely to be a cash based
economy they come to the United States
and they see their colleagues and peers
in college spending without any
connection to what their earning ability
will be so international students tend
to be quite shocked and somewhat
disdainful of their American colleagues
use of credit last call is for Austin
Texas
hi I am a college student and I have
around thirteen thousand dollars of
credit card debt however it's at 1.9% I
mean I know that a bank would never lend
me at 1.9% so I think credit cards are
great I had cash I would just spend the
cash without knowing where I would go
and so I I think critical eyes are
awesome callers stay on the line I want
our guests to respond well again if it's
not the credit card that's the problem
it's a person that using it this seems
to be a savvy caller for lost in Texas
and if she can get one point nine
percent for the next five years I'd Pat
her on the back but I would caution her
that the tops ten credit card companies
control eighty-five percent of the
market and you're not going to be able
to rotate that debt at one point nine
percent for much longer call her you
have a response um as far as I know the
city because the the lending the credit
card agency that allowed me to have this
debt and it's at one point nine forever
as far as I know
and so I I even though I just think that
it's just depending on the person you
had the credit card debt I believe I'm
an educated person who granted I put
myself through school and everything and
I think the credit card saved my life
kind of thing because otherwise all
these other
people who go through school a parents
pay for everything and I had to pay for
myself without the credit card I
wouldn't have been able to complete
college call her thanks she said the
credit card company allowed her to have
this debt that was an interesting I know
it sounds like it might have been some
kind of credit counseling agreement
again I think one of the things we need
to realize right now is were at the
lowest point in history in terms of
interest rates across the country
whether it's a mortgage whether it's a
credit card I think that most people
should recognize especially if they've
refinanced that in a year or so we're
gonna see a much different credit and
interest rate environment people that
are just making it now at these interest
rates without any changes in their
lifestyle are suddenly gonna find
themselves paying hundreds if not
thousands of dollars a year more in
interest fees and they need to start
looking very clearly at their budget I
strongly encourage them to go to my
website at credit card nation.com and
look at some opportunities to plan their
budgets to look at how to manage their
credit cards more effectively and really
take control take responsibility because
once you're in this situation and you're
in over your head with debt there's only
one person that's going to get you out
of it in this environment particularly
with a new potentially restrictive
bankruptcy law that's just a matter of
years from passage rubber-banding is the
author of credit card nation the
consequences of America's addiction to
credit thanks for spending your time
with us this morning
my pleasure